[Music]
the only gas Wilma Marie still uses is
for the tea lights used for improvised
stove the terracotta pots retain heat
which helps keep her a little warmer as
the Colder Weather approaches
the shop owner decided to have her gas
cut off after her bill doubled to 345
dollars a month with a warning from her
provider that it could reach 700 dollars
my shop has hardly any income I lost
customers during the covid-19 pandemic
and now inflation is so high people
don't have money to buy children's
clothes so my income has really dropped
below minimum I know I can't pay these
high energy bills
while it's getting colder in her house
behind these doors millions of
chrysanthemums are thriving in warm
temperatures but Greenhouse Farmers
depend on gas to continue operating
during winter and many have decided to
stop growing flowers and vegetables in
the next few months something that could
seriously affect Dodge exports
normally if we have like every year like
10 extra cost there's no no problem but
it's now like 10 times more than two
years ago it's crazy in this way if
nobody can survive no company no people
with a household no nobody
with new techniques that use less fossil
fuels while to devastane hopes to be
able to continue his business although
he's worried that the prices of flowers
will climb so high that the month will
dry up the Dutch pay twice as much for
gas as other Europeans due to Hefty
energy tax and their dependence on gas
to generate electricity and while other
EU members have kept their energy prices
the Dutch government is being accused of
doing too little too late
protesters carrying flags upside down
boot the royal family after King William
Alexander delivered his annual budget
address promising a price cap on energy
and 18 billion dollars to compensate
poor families a recent survey suggests
that 7 in 10 Dutch citizens have lost
trust in the government
if you get problems of whether you can
pay your food and energy because that's
what we're talking about even if they
work full-time if they can still pay the
basic necessities then yeah that's the
best way of eroding trust in your own
government
opposition parties say that the
government's Aid package has not been
thought through and fear it won't be
enough to keep the country warm this
winter and that plans to support
entrepreneurs to keep their businesses
running are too vague and have come too
late stop fast and Al Jazeera hook Von
Holland the Netherlands